tripod class you won't even be able to
be mad at me because you'll see I'm
being very fair Eddie was I not being
there I was being fair and she took my
and she tried manipulating it to go for
her cult following is she talking about
the clips what is she saying here she's
talking about the show where she
embarrassed herself which she would not
have to manipulate you it's two and a
half hours unedited some people see I
don't know it was like I'm trying to
remember her show exactly I remember
it's hard because that's why I think
we're gonna edit it in or something but
basically what happened was she came on
the show and she told this story about
her like her husband at the time she
left him because he might cheat like he
said I might cheat and then it was like
oh we're not together now but we'll be
together later my child's fine and then
she was saying how she was not a
feminine woman then but she's a feminine
woman now and I said well how like if
you're a feminine woman like what have
you done because there's this it's not
just her like a lot of times girls come
on the show and they think it's just
them that I'm basing these conclusions
on but there's a whole group of like
YouTubers that they're like femininity
coaches or they talk about being
feminine and they've done no work they
just say they're feminine one day
they're like oh I'm feminine now and I'm
like okay well have you been in a
relationship where that guy will co-sign
that you're feminine and you've been
practicing it right have you been
learning to cook like what specifically
have you done like you still work you
just watched a few YouTube videos I
think the thing that stood out was she
started off talking and talking and
talking and talking and talking and then
suddenly she mentioned she had a child
yeah that's a bombshell he didn't like
the way she did that the way it switched
because we're all giving her advice as a
single married woman and then all of a
sudden it was like and my child she sort
of slipped that she had a child in there
and then the whole conversation changed
and she didn't like him yeah and then um
so Carnival is like a crazy Festival
here right and you saw the video I did
and so she talked about and I think
she's going to talk about this she
talked about how she went to she went to
Carnival which at first it was like
you're a single woman but how are you
traditional and you're at carnival right
and I don't claim to be like the epitome
of traditional women however like I only
went to Carnival to do interviews and
like I'm sorry the women that I know
that are the most feminine and the most
traditional you could not oh my God my
dog
um you could not not too many Housewives
at a carnival no no but the thing is is
that for Pearl it was like a culture
shock but women married women do codes
of Carnival traditional women they do go
to Carnival but what they do is that
they make sure if you're going to go to
Carnival you there's two days to go to
Carnival there's children's day and
there's the adults day so if I'm going
to take a child if I'm going to go to a
carnival by myself as a married woman I
would either go with my man on a Monday
or unless you're in a band you'd go on a
Sunday so you do take children on a
Sunday but you get them home before
bedtime yeah I have a sneaking suspicion
she didn't bring her kid to the kids day
one well she comes to just she
contradicted herself and that's what
happened like she would tell these
stories and then later like I would be
like okay this doesn't make sense but
like like that's what would happen is
she because I was listening and then
later she would say things that kind of
like contradicted herself yeah and then
I would be like okay I'm just being real
with you you hear I didn't make you say
this this is based on the words that
came out of your mouth this isn't making
sense and then she's like you
manipulated me but the thing is like
modern women are so used to not having
pushback for anything that they don't
even realize how delusional they sound
like she I bet you she has no idea she
talks for 60 70 of a podcast with 10
people on it you'd be surprised
she says it on him that she talked much
she thanked you for giving her all that
time on the show oh okay let's see so
her men can be like yeah that girl's
chatting [ __ ] yo man I don't mean like
putting what you're saying because
that's a lie before we use if you watch
the full podcast you will see nothing
was clipped she wish it was clipped to
make her look good but enough it was
clipped and even after it was clipped
but I always say to people that when you
see things like this go and watch the
whole podcast before you make a decision
based on five minutes what did you see
okay for example for example if I say
when I go out on the streets men
approach me right does she look
approachable and then she said that men
will grabbing her in Morocco but she
actually said it next to Moroccan who
pulled her up about it because the men
weren't grabbing her the men were
approaching her because she's in a
tourist area is obviously she looked
like that then she switched and said
even when I go home to India but
obviously you don't trust traditional
look at her Indian women do not expose
themselves like that when you go to
Morocco people go to Morocco as tourists
but if you there's some places you go go
to where it's safer and it's more
traditional for women to cover yourself
up if you look at some of the um female
reporters when they go certain places
they will put on the scarf they will
cover up themselves I'm not saying all
men I'm saying men I get more approach
she might not get approached the way I
get approached yeah because you're so
out of shape
they might not find her attractive many
reasons yeah what are the reasons Phil
give us a reason you're not attractive
Phil and again her cult follow-up one of
the reasons is not because you're away
will find me unattracted attractive but
her beautiful
she knows that I'm now me too me tooing
all men I'm saying that all men harass
me I'm not saying we always talk in a
majority she didn't say that some men
harass her she said all men harass her I
mean she's she's casting a vision for
society where she can't even go in
public yeah she can't even go in public
and that that was the point I was making
where she was saying like everywhere I
go these people approach me and I'm like
you realize like and I I don't remember
off the top of my head but I believe I
said something along the lines of like
this is why men will say you're me
tooing everyone because because you're
you're casting a certain light on men
and I'm just saying that's a shitty way
to look at men I agree and I don't I
don't think like I wouldn't want to be
Associated if they said oh I can't go
anywhere like women are always touching
me like like that that's a shitty light
on woman yeah and I just think like you
need to be careful about the things that
you say yeah and especially if you're
going to generalize about a group of
people and I I really wish I knew the
time stamps of that video because I'd
like to pull it up but we can we could
go back to it later is this a clip
there's many Clips no listen no no no no
no no no did you did you inter shout out
to my content team in Nigeria
yeah shout out Chris Shout Out Chris
he pulls lots of clips from you you mean
you have ethnic people doing your videos
yeah yeah oh wow yeah yeah doesn't
matter opposite to us
did she say you're saying oh man a
person says that she said she then
labeled it this woman is me tooing all
men thumbnail yes
you're gonna have to do that if I know I
don't like if someone came on my podcast
I know I'm doing a genuine podcast by
the way she hasn't got a podcast yet I
will not manipulate for clickbait I
don't do that wait she doesn't have a
podcast no she said she's gonna have one
oh I thought she had a podcast no she
doesn't the other girl has she will say
later on oh yeah
I would say anyone that comes I love I
love people that have never done the job
and just think they can do it better
they're really Pleasant let me let me go
up to Jeff Bezos and tell him how to run
Amazon but the thing is what she doesn't
realize that she's got the perfect pod
whatever you say for us in our
thumbnails we'll just Elevate and we
might of course for example when you
came in and said your dad had two wives
yeah we we said oh your dad had two
wives because that's what you said yeah
we didn't say like this woman Advocates
that every man should have exactly is
that he's spinning exactly yeah
there's only one aspect to it the other
important bit is what you actually see
and that's yeah and that's what I said
to you like it's important as a
podcaster it's a skill a lot of people
think you just come here and talk yeah
it's your ability to control The
Narrative of the conversation
but also and again maybe this is where
the cultural differences are when it
comes to even like me traveling as an
Asian woman they don't see me as my
British passport they see me as an Asian
woman if I go to Dubai they see me as a
Bangladeshi woman and they will take
advantage of that thinking I'm a
Bangladeshi woman it's just interesting
um because I know a couple people from
those countries and they don't actually
have the same views as you that grew up
in the like like um you said well I
think you said Morocco yeah
majority I'll say this the context on in
which this happened you were on holiday
right you're right about the pillow
I've noticed I'm Banning them from the
show and you're saying that people
grabbed you what was the context of that
group no I'm not saying that they're
constantly grabbing this approach a
constantly trying to talk yeah it's
changing yeah I'm changing should we go
further back before
you can be quite shy and introvert me
personally I'm very very shy but when
you are in a situation where you feel
comfortable you can come out of your
shell and with some guys you know with
some girls they can come out their shell
whereas other women have made them feel
no you stay shy because women
I don't think that I think guys will
approach you if they feel good about
themselves so if they feel like they're
you know put pushing gym or whatever
that to build their own self-confidence
I I know guys that feel good about
themselves like they're like yeah I'm
good looking I go to the gym you know
I'm a nice person and he won't approach
a girl but he'll look at a girl and be
like no I won't approach her because we
we like or that girl looks so good and
this is the death of femininity I think
a lot more women are masculine because
back in the day women would signal and
even when we had kit on the other day he
he educates women yeah he educates women
how to signal to allow a man to to feel
comfortable enough to get um to approach
again
maybe the problem is men aren't actually
looking for women's signal before
they're approaching so when a girl is
now calling Paw Patrol is because she's
not signaled to you she's not showed you
she's any interest in you don't know
what her relationship status is and
maybe wait for the cues for a woman
yeah
can I say this I think women import the
masculinity more now 100
okay you notice she's trying to talk you
interrupt she's trying to talk you and
her every single time I don't know if
anyone else uses tfl regularly maybe I'm
poor but you know go on the tube you see
the advert I um stare and harassment
yeah
it puts men on edge yeah
but if we flip it to like countries
where there isn't that a lot of men take
advantage so it's not these aren't put
in there for women do the majority of
men are the majority of men the men
you're describing sorry a majority of
men Dominion describing so the men
you're saying that take advantage of the
country like where this isn't the social
Norm just answer the question where you
have to but is that the majority of men
sorry is that do you so the majority of
yeah go on do you think the majority of
men are doing that in those countries in
those countries what going up to women
unsolicited yeah 100 normal okay boom
majority amen boom
majority of men approach
majority is it that much better
shemitude the majority of men is that
Kobe Kobe is that
is that is that much better than all men
it's not taken out of context at all I
mean you could literally just put quote
majority of men end quote in developing
countries or sex offenders that's what
she's saying you know what you know what
hold up hold up I'm gonna
Zariah if you're watching this I'm gonna
switch it for you I'm gonna put
the majority just to make it a little
more accurate maybe I see where you're
coming from yeah maybe I see where she
worship the majority of men you're right
so she's like there's like a 10 of men
that are just so socially anxious they
won't approach anybody the other 90 are
all vicious yep vile you know she is me
too and the thing is how many times how
many times was that question asked how
many times to get to the answer Yeah
Eddie asks the question you ask the
question I'm sure idiots a couple of
times you watched a couple of times
before she actually came up with an
answer